RFK told uh Rogan a little bit about the
time he first met Anthony fauci
2016 Donald Trump asked me to serve on a
vaccine safety commission and I agreed
to do it and I and he then ordered fauci
and Collins to meet with me and you know
Peter marks at FDA you know so I had
meetings with all these guys so you know
I said to him Tony you've said been
telling people I'm a liar
when I say no vaccine has ever been not
none of the mandated vaccines what they
call recommended they're actually
mandated in many of the states
and none of them have ever been tested
against uh in a placebo-controlled trial
and a safety test prior to licensing
and I said can you show me one
vaccine that has been subject to a safe
test show me one study that shows that
and he made it this show of looking
through a red well
they had brought in from NIH this big
tray full of file folders and he made a
show of kind of looking through that at
the time but he couldn't find whatever
he was looking for so then he said it's
back in NIH in Bethesda
and I'll send it to you well he never
did
so Aaron and I sued him sued HHS and and
said show us one study that's ever been
done on you know pre-licensing safety
testing for vaccines
and after a year of stone stonewalling
they finally gave us a letter and said
we don't have any
does that guy strike you as a crank and
a conspiracy theorist does that story
ring true to you or not did he actually
do the lawsuit yeah he did we checked
do you get it do you get it
now watch as we very smoothly move into
a wonderful compilation of Anthony fauci
lying about everything
but they're really criticizing science
because I represent science
if you're vaccinated you really don't
need to worry about
getting it in a way that's serious or
transmitting it
that is true that is correct Chris
they're really to protect you completely
against infection and the chances are
very likely that you'll not be able to
transmit it to other people the wrist is
extremely low of transmitting it to
anybody else
full-stoxinated people are clearly
capable of transmitting the infection
[Music]
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people feel a
little bit better if people are not
wearing masks then maybe we should be
mandating it I often myself wear two
masks and I'm quoting you now at the
population level masks work at the
margins maybe 10 to hear that they only
work at the margins maybe 10 would make
a lot of people ask okay then why was I
wearing a mask you're really attacking
not only Dr Anthony fauci you're
attacking science when you say that this
is going to go away tomorrow like magic
when you know that there's no chance
it's going to just disappear we hope
this just goes away Burns itself out
so my question is why weren't you
straight with the American people about
this to begin with so the bottom line is
it's a guesstimate I gave a range it
seemed in that quote to suggest that you
were basing your uh your recommendation
on polling and what people could accept
is that not what you meant
[Music]
no I mean it's it's a bit of that guys
this video goes on for about five
minutes we we sure did for the purposes
of the show today but that thing I am
the science it is literally Emperor
Palpatine in Revenge of the Sith I am
the Senate it's treason that these
people are completely out of control